I don't think I've ever seen anybody on
Alistair Campbell's show James O'Brien
show
the Emily Maitland show that directly
and openly challenges their world view
now why do I say that because if you
look at the evidence on Elite graduates
or social liberals
they are consistently the most likely to
unfriend block and insult people who
hold different beliefs to their own
they're the most likely to say they
would feel uncomfortable if one of their
kids married somebody who voted for
brexit or somebody who who held gender
critical views so the idea that we have
a kind of liberal enlightened tolerant
open Elite Class I'm afraid I don't see
it I see a group that is basically
trying to shut down or stigmatize people
who want to challenge the consensus and
that to me is not liberal at all